Russian President Vladimir Putin is
welcoming that plan to remove US troops
from Syria Putin is holding his famously
long end of year news conference in
Moscow this morning he's taking
questions from hundreds of Russian and
foreign journalists our Charlie d'Agata
is there and joins us from Moscow
Charlie good morning good morning well
it's been another marathon press
conference on subjects ranging from the
situation in Ukraine to why President
Putin isn't married yet now on the topic
of US troop withdrawal from Syria the
president called the American presence
there illegitimate in the first place as
for defeating Isis I do generally agree
with the President of the United States
we've achieved some major advances when
it comes to defeating the terrorists and
we have struck major blows on terrorists
in Syria whether do we need the presence
of the American military I guess we do
not need that presence the presence of
your troops is illegitimate so if you've
made this decision it is the right
decision President Putin also warned
about the rise in the threat of a
nuclear war saying if the United States
puts intermediate missiles in Europe
Russia will be forced to take
countermeasures John Charlie d'Agata and
Moscow thank you Charlie